hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr eingeschaltet habt
Chinas Staats- und parteichefijin Ping
ist heute zu einem dreitägigen
Staatsbesuch nach Russland gereist das
ist der erste Besuch hierjingpings
seitdem Putin die Ukraine angegriffen
hat also vor knapp einem Jahr und jetzt
guckt die internationale Gemeinschaft
natürlich heute auf dieses Treffen und
fragt sich was wird da wohl besprochen
der chinesische Außenminister waren wenn
bin hat gesagt die Reise sei ein Besuch
für den Frieden und in dieser
Vermittlerrolle hat sich China zuletzt
ja öfter inszeniert china hat sich
wiederholt gegen einen Atomwaffeneinsatz
ausgesprochen Ende Februar wurde so ein
12 Punkteplan für die Ukraine
präsentiert Seiten China ist bei genauem
Hinsehen entpuppte sich der aber eher
als Unterstützung Russlands und bis
heute hat China den Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine auch nicht verurteilt
spricht immer noch von Krise statt Krieg
es wird bei diesem Besuch den ihr da
gerade sieht aber wohl auch um
wirtschaftliche Interessen gehen der
Handel zwischen den beiden Staaten ist
im letzten Jahr um mehr als 30 Prozent
gestiegen auf 190 Milliarden US-Dollar
auch wegen der westlichen Sanktionen
gegen Moskau und deswegen fragen wir uns
heute wie eng ist das Verhältnis
zwischen Russland und China wirklich und
welche Ziele verfolgt China aktuell
darüber spreche ich mit unserem
zdf-korrespondenten in Moskau Christian
SEM und mit Nico rotary er ist Direktor
des Mercator Institute for China studies
wenn ihr Fragen an die beiden habt oder
mit uns hier im Studio diskutieren wollt
dann könnt ihr das wie immer gerne
machen schreibt uns einfach hier im
Youtube Chat oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de und jetzt gehen wir
aber erstmal direkt an den Ort des
Geschehens nach Moskau hallo Christian
hallo schönen guten Abend Christian was
erwartet man denn von russischer Seite
von diesem Treffen mit China ist das
wirklich ein wie China sagt Besuch für
den Frieden
also aus russischer Sicht gibt es da
mehrere Punkte der Besuch ist vor allem
wichtig für Wladimir Putin wir haben die
Bilder schon gesehen von den beiden von
Präsident hier und Präsident Putin so
oft kommt es in Moskau ja nicht mehr vor
dass ihr internationale Staatsgäste
kommen und dann noch so hochrangig das
ist wichtig für Putin weil er mit diesen
Bildern der Welt zeigen kann auch dem
eigenen Volk den Russen und Russen und
vor allem den besten zeigen kann seht
her Russland ist gar nicht so alleine
wie immer behauptet wir haben auf der
Weltbühne haben wir noch Verbündete die
zu uns halten die uns besuchen die mit
uns ins Gespräch kommen und die uns
nicht ins Abseits stellen so wie ihr das
macht ähm du hast die wirtschaftlichen
Verbindungen auch schon angesprochen die
sind gewachsen ähm seit dem russischen
Angriff auf die Ukraine da sehen beide
Länder aber noch Potential das dann noch
mehr geht also es wird natürlich auch um
wichtige wirtschaftliche Fragen gehen
und ähm ein Putin Berater hat vorher
auch kurz über die bevorstehenden
Gespräche gesprochen hat gesagt das wird
natürlich im Wirtschaft gehen es wird
darum Energie Fragen gehen und auch wie
er es genannt hat um Militär isch
technische Zusammenarbeit
du hast ja gerade schon angesprochen
dieses Gefühl von internationaler
Isolation das passt natürlich perfekt zu
diesem Haftbefehl den es am Freitag gab
gegen Putin da hat der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof in Den Haag ein
Haftbefehl gegen Putin und eine sagen
wir mal enge Mitarbeiterinnen Putins
erlassen jetzt ist ja Putin an diesem
Wochenende ganz demonstrativ durch das
ukrainische mariopol gelaufen empfängt
jetzt hohen Besuch hat dieser haftbeflos
eigentlich irgendeinen Einfluss auf ihn
der hat hier auf jeden Fall Einfluss
also das wurde gehört man denkt ja auch
wenn solche Botschaften Richtung
Russland kommen dass das hier alles
abprallt das mag nach außen hin so sein
auch wenn sich Pressesprecher
gremmelsprecher pestov in seinen
täglichen pressebriefings dazu äußert
und die Dinge abtut aber das wird ja
schon gehört und diskutiert und genau
hingeschaut von wem solche Nachrichten
kommen und eben jetzt vom vom
internationalen Gericht das wird ja
schon gesehen und diskutiert und das
haben viele auch als Beleidigung
empfunden auch gegenüber ihrem
Präsidenten und China hat sich da eben
auch nicht so festgelegt und das wird
den Chinesen jetzt natürlich wiederum
vorgeworfen
aber in Russland ist die Haltung da ganz
klar man findet das natürlich nicht gut
und versucht sozusagen den Präsidenten
zu schützen und ich glaube der Besuch
von Putin ähm wir haben auch die Bilder
gesehen wie er da durchs nächtliche
mariopol fährt Leute trifft
das war natürlich in den Augen vieler
ein bizarrer Auftritt aber ich glaube es
war auch im Vorfeld
das besucht jetzt von Gin Ping ganz
bewusst gesetzt um eben noch mal klar
festzulegen welche Haltung Russland auch
für mögliche Friedensgespräche hat und
das hat der Kreml das hat Putin immer
wiederholt das Kiew diese neuen
Realitäten diese territorialen
neuen Abschnitte die und Gebiete die
Russland sich einfallleiterte
einverleibt hat das kieft das eben
anerkennen müsse und Putin betont ja
auch immer wieder dass die Ziele die
Russland in der Ukraine hat dass die
eben nur militärisch zu erreichen sein
im Moment
lass uns mal auf das Treffen gucken wir
haben heute Tag eins ich glaube andere
Raum sind drei Tage hast du heute schon
irgendwas mitbekommen wie es läuft wie
die Stimmung ist was vielleicht
besprochen wurde
also wir haben es gesehen die
auftaktbilder das waren eine herzliche
Begrüßung und dem vorweg ging ja auch
zwei große Artikel einmal in
chinesischen Zeitung und einmal in
russischen Zeitungen wo die beiden
Staatsführer jeweils noch mal die
Wichtigkeit dieser Beziehung bekundet
haben die Freundschaft und einfach noch
mal sehr darauf hingewiesen haben wie
wichtig diese Partnerschaft doch ist
Putin hat betont dass die Beziehung noch
nie so gut gewesen sein wie ähm wie
heutzutage und die Begrüßung waren dann
eben auch entsprechend herzlich ähm man
hat sich im Kreml getroffen und von
offizieller Seite heißt es dass heute
der erste Tag sei eher so der informelle
Tag also man kommt zusammen man kommt
ins Gespräch man ist zusammen Mittag man
hat dann noch mal Zeit für einen
intensives vier Augen Gespräch um alle
möglichen Themen zu erörtern und lässt
den Abend dann gemütlich ausklingen
bei einem sieben Gänge Menü und genießt
sozusagen die Zeit zusammen und pflegt
die Freundschaft die bei der immer
wieder betonen und morgen soll es dann
sozusagen richtig auf die Arbeitsebene
gehen da wollen dann beide Delegationen
auch wirklich miteinander verhandeln
dann wird es eben um die Fragen gehen
über die wir schon gesprochen haben also
um Wirtschaft und um Energie und auch
uns Militär und natürlich auch um die
Frage der Ukraine da ist eben dann die
genaue Frage und das weiß momentan
keiner wie sehr Siegen da versuchen wird
auf Vladimir Putin einzuwirken
ja der erste von drei Tagen wir sind
gespannt was noch passiert vielen Dank
Christian für deine Einschätzung vor Ort
wir haben schon gehört es wird von
Partnerschaft gesprochen aber wir
sollten jetzt mal gucken an welchen
Punkten diese Partnerschaft eigentlich
wichtig ist an welchen Punkten China und
Russland kooperieren und dann welchen
Punkten sich auch Interessen
überschneiden die beiden also
voneinander profitieren hier schreibt
schon jemand aus der Community diese
Entwicklung war abzusehen
wirtschaftsinteresse und Verbundenheit
aus ähnlichen Motiven ja und genau
zusammengefasst hat das Axel Konrad für
uns
Russland und China hier das größte da
das bevölkerungsreichste Land der Erde
zwei Supermächte die viel eint und die
voneinander profitieren
Stichwort Handel vergangenes Jahr ist
der um 30 Prozent gestiegen Öl und Gas
aus Russland sind für das
wachstumshungrige China so billig wie
nie und Russland nimmt seit den
westlichen Sanktionen von China was ist
kriegen kann und hofft auch auf Waffen
für Russland ist China Handelspartner
Nummer eins umgekehrt gilt das nicht
Stichwort Geostrategie Russland und
China zwei Mächte mit expansionstrang
und einem gemeinsamen Gegner dem das
nicht passt die USA das gemeinsame Ziel
eine Chinesisch russisch dominierte
Weltordnung Stichwort Politik und
Gesellschaft beide einst die Ablehnung
westlich liberaler Werte die
Verherrlichung eines autoritären ein
Personenkults und die Verfolgung von
Andersdenkenden
Russland braucht China viel mehr als
umgekehrt China dagegen darf nur so
russlandfreundlich sein dass es seine
westlichen Handelspartner nicht
verprellt
dann über diesen Balanceakt
ihr habt Fragen oder wollt eure Meinung
mit uns teilen dann schreibt uns gerne
im Youtube Chat oder per Mail Herr
rotary wir haben eben gehört Russland
braucht China viel mehr als umgekehrt
wie sehr braucht China denn Russland
nun Russland ist ein
wichtiger Partner der erstmal sozusagen
ein der größte Nachbar ist da geht es um
eine mehrere tausend Kilometer lange
Grenze eine lange Geschichte auch
Konflikte reiche Geschichte wo sozusagen
Stabilität im Norden für Peking
natürlich oberste Priorität hat auch
China sieht sich in einem Umfeld das
sozusagen instabil wird wo es um globale
Konflikte geht und muss dafür Sicherheit
und Stabilität sorgen das darf man nicht
vergessen
zweiter wichtiger Grund äh Russland ist
ein zentraler Partner geeint im gleichen
Weltbild auf der Suche nach einer neuen
internationalen Ordnung die man eben
versucht durchzusetzen gegen die USA
gegen den Westen wo es auch um
autoritäre Interessen mehr geht als
vielleicht um Demokratie wo es um eigene
Stärke Einfluss werden und ähnliches
gibt hier findet Peking in Moskau ein
willigen Partner und ähm nichts
vergessen es ist gewissermaßen auch ein
Seiteneffekt dieser dieses Kriegs in der
Ukraine ähm dass der Westen die USA
insbesondere abgelenkt sind und
Kapazitäten woanders bündeln müssen und
sich nicht so sehr auf China im Moment
konzentrieren können insofern china hat
durchaus Interesse und auch verfolgt
eigene Ziele in diesem Konflikt
jetzt ersetzen ja gerade
Wirtschaftsinteressen aus China für
Russland auch Wirtschaftsinteressen aus
aus der EU die es vorher gab China
scheint ja so ein bisschen gespalten
gerade inwiefern kann sich China das den
aktuell wirklich leisten jetzt seine
westlichen Handelspartner so zu
verprellen leider versuche es ja genau
hier eine Art Mittelweg zu finden das
genauso zu kalibrieren das möglichst
viel von den westlichen
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen noch erhalten
bleibt und das ist ja im Moment auch der
Fall also insofern gelingt dieser
Ballons oder Drahtseilakt der Führung im
Moment und das man möglichst viele
dennoch unter diesen Bedingungen auch
Putin in den Rücken stärken kann also
tut in den Rücken stärken im Westen
Rücken nicht ähm abzukehren das ist das
Mantra und im Moment scheint dieser
Balance sagt noch weiteres gehen zu
gelingen
du hast es ja eben schon auch so
Entschuldigung wir haben sie eben auch
schon so ein bisschen angesprochen
inwiefern ist das was wir da gerade an
wirtschaftlicher Kooperation sehen auch
eine ideologische Allianz gegen den
Westen gegen die USA
nun da trifft sich schon einiges was
sehr ähnlich gestaltetes im Weltbild und
in der Art und Weise wie man mit seiner
Bevölkerung umgeht mit seinem
politischen System das sind beides
Führer die darauf abzielen nach innen
möglichst viel Kontrolle zu haben und
nach außen macht zu projizieren das
Weltbild das hier westliche Werte
abgelehnt werden Demokratie
Meinungsfreiheit und ähnliches da ist
man sich sehr ähnlich ich glaube aber
dass der ideologische Kit im Moment noch
relativ dünn ist und fragil und das
tatsächlich eher die strategischen
Interessen im Moment noch deutlich
stärker sind und auch hier gibt es
genügend gemeinsame
liegenden die man verfolgen kann
ja wir hören von strategischer
Kooperation wir hören von ideologischen
Ansichten die sich ähneln Elisabeth
Schmidt hat sich für uns mal angeguckt
wie diese Männerfreundschaft aufgestellt
ist und wie viel Friedensbemühungen da
wirklich zu sehen ist
Vladimir Putin und die Pink etwas 40 Mal
haben sich die beiden bislang getroffen
inszenierte Männer Freundschaft der
Kreml Herrscher bewundert Chinas
wirtschaftliche Errungenschaften Pekings
macht aber Mosk aus Härte gegenüber dem
Westen am Rande der Olympischen
Winterspiele in China schwören sich die
beiden Länder grenzenlose Freundschaft
Februar 2022 kurz darauf marschiert
Russland in die Ukraine ein
China nennt den Krieg bis heute eine
Krise befürwortet ihn nicht verurteilt
ihn aber auch nicht mehrere Male
telefoniert sie mit Putin im vergangenen
Jahr kein einziges Mal mit der Ukraine
und china kauft verbilligtes russisches
Gas und Öl und hält damit putinskrieg
finanziell am Leben
November 2022 Kanzler Scholz in Peking
und ein Bekenntnis auch hier spricht
sich gegen den Einsatz von Atomwaffen in
Europa aus die Kriegsfolgen bekommt auch
China zu spüren unterbrochene
Lieferketten steigende Rohstoffpreise
harte Wirtschaft Sanktionen zum
Jahrestag der russischen Invasion
reistinas top-diplomat nach Moskau und
Peking veröffentlicht ein
Positionspapier 12 Punkte für eine
friedliche Lösung des Ukraine Konflikts
doch sie bleiben unkonkret
vergangenen Donnerstag ein erstes
Telefonat zwischen dem chinesischen und
dem ukrainischen Außenminister
vorsichtig und zurückhaltend
ja wir sehen dieser Balanceakt den China
da wirtschaftlich geht den scheint China
auch diplomatisch zu gehen eben haben
wir den zwölf Punkteplan angesprochen
was ist denn ganz konkret von
chinesischer Seite seit Ende Februar
also seit dieser Veröffentlichung des
12-punkte Plans für die Ukraine passiert
und sichtbar abgesehen von dem Telefonat
was gerade angesprochen wurde recht
wenig
und was aber im Kontext passiert ist und
nicht zu unterschätzen vielleicht ist
China hat ein Erfolg vorzuweisen mit
Blick auf seine Fähigkeit diplomatische
Krisen auch durch Vermittlungsleistungen
zu unterstützen im Konflikt zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und Iran hat sich Peking
positionieren können ähm als Vermittler
in Peking auch zu einer Stabilisierung
dieser wichtigen Beziehung beigetragen
also insofern kommt sie hier mit einem
Gepäck nach Moskau das besagt wir können
solche Dinge nun ist dieser Konflikt und
der Krieg Russlands in der Ukraine
natürlich von einem ganz anderen aus wo
es nicht selbstverständlich ist in
welcher Form Peking da zum einen in den
Interesse hätte zum anderen die
Kapazität hätte auch hier wirklich ein
Beitrag zu einer echten genuin und auch
ähm gerechten Friedenslösung zu finden
was hätte denn China ganz konkret davon
wenn der Krieg weitergeht und was hätte
China davon wenn es zu einer
Friedenslösung kommen sollte irgendwann
nun ein festgefahrener frozen-konflikt
der sozusagen Russland nicht
destabilisiert der Putin an der Macht
hält und weiterhin dafür sorgt dass
westliche Aufmerksamkeit militärische
Kapazitäten gebunden sind in dieser
Krise wäre sicherlich kein schlechtes
Ergebnis wenn sie sich zunehmend oder
zusätzlich noch positionieren könnte als
ein Power Broker ein Vermittler
vielleicht nicht als ein
friedensvermittler aber als jemand der
beiträgt zu einer Stabilisierung der
Lage das Täter sichern dem Ansehen
Pekings in der Welt insbesondere im
globalen Süden durchaus gut also
insofern einen festgefahrener
eingefrorener Konflikte bei dem China
seine Hände im Spiel hatte wäre
sicherlich keine schlechte Lösung
gleichzeitig ist auch Peking natürlich
betroffen von dieser globalen Krise die
durch den Krieg Russlands ausgelöst
wurde insofern eine Stabilisierung in
den diplomatischen Beziehungen im
globalen Kontext was die
Wirtschaftsaussichten ähnliches angeht
wäre auch in China Interesse das heißt
die Abwägung hier ist ein Peking
sicherlich nicht ganz so einfach
wir haben auch eine user-frage zu dem
Thema und zwar fragt jelly X79 auf
Youtube die westlichen
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen sind doch viele
interessanter als Russland wieso setzt
China die überhaupt aufs Spiel
und zum einen ist die Hoffnung natürlich
dass man sich zunehmend von diesen
westlichen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
grundsätzlich auch weniger abhängig
machen könnte das ist insofern ein
katalist für ein Programm was sowieso in
Peking gedacht wird man möchte ja
eigenständig und Oma unabhängig gerade
von westliche Technologie Know-how etc
werden und zum zweiten sobald solange
eben beides möglich ist dass man
Russland unterstützt und den Westen
nicht verprellt
umso länger wird der Peking versuchen
das durchzuhalten als Kurs
wenn wir jetzt mal auf die Zeit vor dem
Angriff Angriff Angriffskrieg schauen
wie haben sich denn die diplomatischen
Beziehungen zwischen Russland und China
seit dem verändert also mal so ein
kleiner Blick in die Geschichte wie
waren die davor und wir haben die sich
ganz konkret durch diesen Angriff
verändert
nun unter sie den Ping und der
Herrschaft von Putin gab es eine
deutliche Annäherung der beiden Stadt
man darf nicht vergessen dass eine
durchaus konfliktreiche Beziehung auch
mit nicht immer überlappenden Interessen
gerade in Zentralasien aber beide haben
aus dieser gemeinsamen Ablehnung des
Westens aus einer ähnlichen
bedrohungsperzeption fast Paranoia
könnte man sagen zunehmend Schlüsse
gezogen die sie zusammengeführt haben
Putin und Ski verbindet dabei
tatsächlich eine Männerfreundschaft eine
enge Freundschaft es ist ja einsam in
diesen
Palästen und sich da mit jemand
verständigen zu können der vielleicht
ähnliche Herausforderung hat was
sicherlich wichtig die beiden sehen die
Welt recht ähnlich und diese Annäherung
wurde dann wirklich zu einem Höhepunkt
geführt in der Erklärung dass man ja
sozusagen eine
Freundschaft ohne Grenzen habe
mittlerweile ohne Gebiete ohne ich es
ohne Angelegenheiten bei denen man nicht
kooperieren könnte das war kurz vor
Ausbruch des Kriegs und der russischen
Aggression
und in der seitdem hat sich letztlich
das Bild eigentlich verfestigt wenn wir
genau hinhören was zentrale
Führungskräfte aus Peking gegenüber
Moskau signalisieren es ist der Wunsch
eine Vertiefung der strategischen
Partnerschaft jetzt umschifft man diese
Klauseln dass man sagt Freundschaft ist
vielleicht doch nicht ganz so dicht aber
in der Sache hat sich wenigstens
geändert der Kurs geht weiter
jetzt hat ja eine Recherche von politiko
ergeben dass China zwischen Juni und
Dezember letzten Jahres also 2022 circa
1000 Sturmgewehre nach Russland
geliefert hat teilweise über Umwege und
auch anderes Equipment wo man sich jetzt
streiten kann inwiefern das klar zum
Krieg zuzuordnen ist da geht es um
drohnenteile da geht es um Batterien um
Körperschutz müsste ich China dahinter
den Kulissen nicht doch mehr ein als
vorne rum
China unterstützt Russland und genauso
weit wie es
stand jetzt zumindest nicht zu einem
Bruch mit dem besten kommt und dazu
gehören beispielsweise die Dinge die sie
genannt haben dazu gehört auch die
Tatsache dass es schwere LKWs
beispielsweise dramatisch in der Zahl
gestiegen sind was die exporter aus
China angeht da gehört das Kaufen von
russischen Gütern dazu also insofern das
China Russland nicht unterstützt in
diesem Konflikte ist leider falsch ob es
an schweres militärisches Gerät geht da
scheint im Moment noch die Hürde zu sein
wir hoffen auch und das ist im Moment
kein Anzeichen zu sehen dass sich das
grundsätzlich ändert aber aus der
Perspektive Pekings wäre das durchaus
ein legitimer Schritt der Westen
unterstützt ja die Ukraine insofern
warum sollte es China nicht auch
Russland unterstützen diesen Konflikt
also es ist vielleicht eine Frage der
Kalibrierung im Moment noch das China
aber Russland auch mit Dual use mit
Zivil militärischen Gütern steht außer
Frage
ja wir haben ja vorhin schon den
Haftbefehl angesprochen der Freitag aus
Den Haag kam was ist denn ihre Meinung
beeinflusst der so ein Treffen wie heute
überhaupt
letztlich bestätigt er natürlich beide
Führer in Peking in Moskau in ihren
Ansichten über die Natur der
internationalen Ordnung die natürlich
gegen sie gewendet wird also umso mehr
Grund sich dagegen zu stellen
leider natürlich auch einfach für Big
und hier zu argumentieren dass ein Staat
wie die USA sich doch hier bitte
zurückhaltend dürfe denn auch in
Washington sei ja die Unterstützung für
den Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
durchaus geringen die sich nicht dazu
gemietet haben also insofern eine
Bestätigung vielleicht der eigenen
Einschätzung der internationalen Ordnung
und noch ein weiterer Vorwurf den man
gegen den Westen erheben kann
ja das war ein gutes Stichwort in genau
diesen O-Ton vom US-Außenminister
blinken haben wir jetzt mal rein
das Präsident China Russland reist
nachdem der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof einen Haftbefehl gegen
Präsident Putin erlassen hat deutet
darauf hin dass es sich nicht
verantwortlich fühlt den kremme für
begangene Groll Taten zu Rechenschaft zu
ziehen stattdessen bietet es Russland
diplomatische Rückendeckung damit es
diese Verbrechen weiter begehen kann
ja wenn ich sie jetzt richtig verstanden
habe sie sagen das beeindruckt China
eigentlich gar nicht oder erstmal an
dieser Stelle nicht ich denke
China wird in der Tat weiterhin die
diplomatisch Unterstützung für Russland
hochhalten und noch deutlich mehr tun
sei es im Bereich der Wirtschaft oder
sei es auch in bei der Zusammenarbeit
mit Blick auf strategische Fragen
was haben Sie denn ganz konkret noch für
Erwartungen an die nächsten beiden Tage
mit was für Ergebnissen rechnen sie da
sind das vor allem diplomatische
Bemühungen sind das auch wirtschaftliche
Bemühungen die dazu Tage getreten werden
ich denke wir müssen mit einigen
Ankündigungen rechnen auch gemeinsame
Projekte im Bereich der
Wirtschaftszusammenarbeit noch mal
hochzufahren hier wird man versuchen
sozusagen business as usual ähm zu
signalisieren auch die Zusammenarbeit
bei globalen strategischen Fragen wird
sicherlich noch mal betont werden
regionale Organisationen wie die
Shanghai
kooperationsorganisationen das sind
alles Dinge wo man sozusagen
signalisiert wir sind zusammen wir
stehen zusammen und es wird sicherlich
einiges Angelegenheiten geben auch den
Westen und die EU und die USA zu
kritisieren für ihren Ansatz in dieser
Krise ob es konkret Schritte nach vorne
gibt mit Blick auf eine mögliche
Friedenslösung das ist natürlich der
harte Test im Moment sollten wir da sehr
bescheiden sein was unsere Hoffnung
angeht
und wir haben
Abschied und zwar fragt einen YouTube
User besteht denn die Gefahr dass China
Munition an Russland liefern könnte
inwiefern könnte China auch die
verschleiern
nun die Grenze ist lang es kann viel
verschleiert werden aber im Moment
scheint es doch so dass internationale
Satelliten Aktivitäten und durchaus in
der Lage sind so etwas nachzuverfolgen
es gibt verschleierungsaktivitäten über
Drittländer all das ist denkbar insofern
müssen wir vorsichtig sein mit dem was
wir wirklich auch beobachten können
stand jetzt noch mal unsere Annahme ist
dass wir nicht davon ausgehen dass
hartes militärisches gut geliefert wird
ob das dauerhaft so bleibt ist wie
gesagt der harte Test für diese
Partnerschaft
und eine allerletzte Frage habe ich noch
besser gesagt ha ja Buser Film auf
Youtube äh der User fragt begründet das
Interesse Chinas an den Sibirien
sibirischen sibirischen Gebieten die
Unterstützung für Russland Peking macht
das ja nicht aus Nächstenliebe
und das kann direkt da ähm Zusammenhang
natürlich zu sehen aber das Peking
langfristige Interessen auch im
Verhältnis zu Russland hat die
historisch begründet sind ich glaube da
hat der der Nutzer sicherlich recht ich
würde jetzt nicht im übersprungen davon
ausgehen dass hier ein großer Kuhhandel
stattfindet Unterstützung für Russlands
Krieg in der Ukraine und dann
mittelfristig möglicherweise solche
Dinge wie gebietsaufgaben oder ähnliches
aber das China Tiefe wirtschaftliche
Interessen im Osten Russland verfolgt
und weit darüber hinaus das ist
sicherlich der Fall und Peking wird sich
hier noch deutlich stärker durchsetzen
können mit diesen Interessen im
Verhältnis zur Führung in Moskau
danke für Ihre Antworten herzlichen Dank
ja wir haben heute den ersten Tag dieses
Treffens da sind also noch zwei Tage in
denen eine ganze Menge passieren kann
ich guck mal in Eure Kommentare was ihr
zu diesem Treffen denkt hier schreibt
zum Beispiel radoniki Valentin auf
Facebook es ist klar was China will eine
chinesische Weltordnung die ist aber mit
uns nicht vereinbar ich will diese
Weltordnung nicht ich will auch Putins
Weltordnung nicht wir müssen auf uns
gucken und fertig und Thomas gerade sagt
auf Youtube China sollte sich mal
entscheiden auf welcher Seite sie stehen
jemand anders auf Youtube sagt china hat
sich längst entschieden die Frage ist
nur für was ja mal gucken ob wir am Ende
dieses Treffens ein wenig schlauer sind
über die geopolitischen Strategien
Chinas und auch Russlands ich sehe hier
gerade noch ein Kommentar von Trust
number one auf Youtube der sagt vielen
Dank dass sie demokratisch den
meinungskanal hier offen halten da sage
ich Danke an euch dass ihr immer so
fleißig mit kommentiert und Miss mit
diskutiert wir sehen uns hier wieder bei
ZDF heute live wenn ihr denkt